en el sitio arqueológico mesopotámico de
acá al oeste de bagdad algunos miembros
de una unidad conjunta están patrullando
dos policías un militar y un miembro de
la policía de antigüedades sus hombres
salieron esta mañana y registrar la zona
de nad ali muhamad es policía pero ha
sido asignado por el ministerio de
cultura recibió clases durante tres
meses sobre las antigüedades y su
historia su misión garantizar que no
ocurra ningún saqueo en este sitio
en caso de que constatemos infracciones
en los notificó de inmediato a mi
superior la policía llama a la estación
más cercana y el ejército a su unidad
es así como cooperamos si observamos una
falla de seguridad a lo largo de los
últimos años han tenido lugar pocos
saqueos según él debido al apoyo de la
población y la presencia militar pero la
situación sigue siendo peligrosa
es peligroso porque si un grupo está
decidido a saquear cualquier cosa para
lograrlo
disparar para matar a mi familia
caminal es que vienen a robar
de este lugar
metheny
las operaciones son peligrosas pero
valiosas en estas imágenes decenas de
objetos de la época sumeria y babilónica
recuperados durante una de ellas en el
sur del país algunos datan de hace más
de 5.000 años el botín tendría un valor
de varios millones de dólares 450
objetos como estos fueron recuperados en
2019 en una sola provincia de di kar
donde los saqueadores o pelé
en especial en época de coronavirus los
observadores de este tráfico constatan
un aumento de la actividad desde el
inicio de la pandemia la unesco expresa
su preocupación a muchos sitios
arqueológicos y museos están abandonados
debido a la pandemia
y ello permite un acceso más fácil
y el coronavirus permitió un movimiento
en la red porque justamente ya no hay
movimientos de personas entonces se
vuelca internet y son más difíciles de
monitorear
este representante afirma sin embargo
que estos últimos años han permitido
tomar conciencia en la importancia de
esta luz sobre todo con la situación en
siria e irak en los años 2014 y 2015 eso
creó un impacto tanto en las autoridades
como la población y en la opinión
pública recordemos en 2017 aquella
reunión del consejo de seguridad que por
primera vez decide que el ataque a los
bienes del patrimonio es un crimen de
guerra y un atentado contra la humanidad
estas imágenes de propaganda del grupo
estado islámico produjeron una conmoción
mundial aquí en la ciudad de parte atrás
o en mi ruta capital del imperio neo
asirio hoy en día sabemos que el estado
islámico saqueaba sistemáticamente estos
lugares en el norte de irak lo que le
dejaba a este grupo cientos de millones
de dólares además de generar un problema
de seguridad internacional
estos aquellos privan al país de su
historia el museo nacional de bagdad
constituye un ejemplo de esta hemorragia
del patrimonio en 2003 15.000
antigüedades fueron robadas los
empleados lo recuerdan como si hubiese
sido ayer
nuestros museos y sus colecciones fueron
muy expuestos en este museo nacional con
los eventos del 2003 y también otros
museos en otras provincias estos
crímenes ya apuntan siempre a los
orígenes de la civilización para borrar
la identidad nacional del país
en especial de un país tan importante
con el drac uno de los orígenes de esta
civilización origen de la escritura
me va a explicar el que está ver
mientras la situación en materia de
seguridad no se estabilice en irak los
saqueos continuarán asegura este experto
en los conflictos armados crearon una
situación frágil en materia de seguridad
de ciertas zonas la vigilancia se volvió
la existen varias regiones de irak donde
es difícil garantizar el control
cerca de un tercio de los objetos
robados en este museo fueron encontrados
durante los últimos 15 años tienen la
ventaja de haber sido registrados y por
ende es más fácil identificarlos en los
mercados internacionales a diferencia de
los extraídos en las excavaciones
clandestinas que serán probablemente
tesoros culturales perdidos para siempre